chichi gonzalez getting back into action
for the first time since last saturday
at oracle park in san francisco second
start of the year fourth appearance
overall for chi-chi today 1-0 3.60
earned run average
2-2 strike
three
and dominic smith is the first out of
the inning
change-up up and away from dominic it
was
closer look
right on the corner this is pitch number
10 coming up really good speed on base
for the mets
swung on in missed
chichi wins the battle
two outs
wow what a battle it was too 10 pitches
later
great look on the subaru super mo
alonzo thought he was on this one too
just a late movement
toyota numbers for jacob degrom are
always great but even in colorado he's
had two starts era just two and a half
he's made 16 straight
starts on the road and has not lost a
ball game
which is a new mets club record breaking
the mark jointly held by dwight gooden
and
ron darling
and story goes down swinging and degroms
got his first strike out of the day one
two three for jake in the thin air no
score after one
two balls two strikes on fuentes pitch
it's in there strike three called
fastball over the outer half of the
plate froze fuentes
the grom gets a much needed strikeout
his second of the day one out here in
the second hillyard strikes out last
struck out last year at a rate of 37
of his at-bats just 210 last year
and he comes inside again and strikes
him out on three pitches all the same 99
or 100 inside corner or just
in a little further a two and two count
on dom nunez two out two on no score
second inning the gromps pitch
swinging a missed strike three went to
the back foot slider he got nunez to
chase and jacob degrom with three
straight strikeouts takes lifetime
average now up to 194.
that's hit the other way and that's
going to fall into left field for a base
hit
and now he's hitting 667.
so degrom continues to rake
four for six to start the year
a little cutter on the outside part kind
of maybe semi jams himself but dumps it
into left field
it's been that good in this
first few seasons
2-2 pitch swinging a bouncer to the
right side mcmahon a diving stop and
short right gets up and throws him out
what a play by ryan mcmahon to take a
base hit away from lindor degrom to
third but a sparkling defensive effort
by the rocky's second baseman we'll
bring up pete alonso with a couple on
runners at the corners for the mets
1-0 pitch line drive that is going to
drop in for a base hit into center field
hilliard feels degrom will score
and heading over to third on the play
is brandon nimmo rbi single for pete
alonso the mets strike first they lead
it one nothing here in the top of the
third a big two out base hit as chi-chi
gonzalez got a fastball right around
beltai outer half of the plate
and now the 2-2
swing and a mess strike three got him
with a fast ball up
for seamer and strikeout number five on
the afternoon for jacob degrom oh and
two on tapia and jake ready now deals
swing and a miss another one up and
tapia on three pitches heads back to the
rockies bench that is
five in a row
struck out by degrom and six on the
afternoon i think jake has found his
groove there wayne
and he blows him away upstairs degrom
strikes out the side he's fanned the
last six hitters degrom on a roll
talking about a shutdown inning
one-nothing minutes well degram has
struck out six in a row
and stories foul tips one for strength
three and that's seven in a row for
degrom
starting with a slider and then after
that fastballs kept going up in the zone
well now not only is degrom on a roll
but now he's got the shadows starting to
work in his favor too again the 2-2 to
blackman
and he struck him out
eight in a row for jacob degram that
ties his career best third time in his
career he's struck at eight straight
fulfilling prophecy they're looking for
fastball they get it they've just never
seen it
this quick one-two coming
he struck him out nine in a row for
jacob degrom
ten strikeouts for the day
one strikeout shy of history jacob
degrom he has struck out nine
consecutive batters one shy of the major
league record set by the most famous men
of all time
just look at degrom oh well he's not
going to have a record
it's thrown away fuentes will stay in
foul ground so
josh will reach on the throwing error by
jeff mcneal
dom nunez comes up with one out fuentes
at first reaching on that mcneil error
this guy this ball driven high and deep
right field way back and off the wall
fuentes will get a green light from stu
cole he'll score easily nunez after the
caramel on his way to third triple and
we're all tied up
dom nunez has tied this thing up
you talked about the swings that he took
his first at bat he just missed some
fastballs this time he does not miss a
fastball question was it going to get
out of here got it pretty high about
three quarters of the wall way up that
auxiliary scoreboard
and a runner at third with one out for
the rockies
pinch hitter yana than daza down two
strikes
the grom fires and dom drives it to
right field coming on conforto stabs the
liner nunez trying to score and he's in
there as the throw is not handled by
mccann the rockies lead it 2-1
really terrific job by dazza put the bat
on the ball forced the defense to make a
play
this ball is well hit to right
[Applause]
all those mets fans on the third base
line in shock right now
that is the second home run that degrama
has given up this year both of them to
left-handers
[Applause]
alonso mcneil and conforto for the mets
in the top of the sixth
and pika to breaking ball and drills one
down the left field line toward the wall
it's out of here
pete alonso with a line drive home run
his second of the year to get the mets
back within a run
that was an absolute bullet off the bat
of alonso 10 rows up into the seats in
left field but gary you talked about
that series he had two seasons ago here
in colorado
to some hitters just who doesn't like
hitting here
and blackman did he go around he did
strike three number 13 for degrom and
somebody else finished the bottom of the
seven swing and a miss krone is down on
strikes and that is 14 strikeouts for a
second consecutive start for jacob
degrom
tying running first and nobody else vr
rifles one into right field for a base
hit that ball is going to go back to the
wall amore on his way to third gary
desarcina is going to wave him around
the relay throw to the plate by mcmahon
he slides in head first and he's safe
the mets tie the game
jonathan vr with the rbi double elmore
just beat the relay by mcmahon and the
mets get even three to three in the
seventh great speed a third nimmo with
great speed at first
and lendore hits it hard base hit and
the mets take the lead vr is in to score
francisco lindor with the mets fourth
consecutive hit puts new york in front
it's four to three in the seventh just
his second rbi has ahmed and his biggest
so far lindor with the base hit to give
the mental lead
struck him out
high heat from edwin diaz
one two coming to hilliard he struck him
out
back-to-back strikeouts for diaz yes to
nunez
struck him out and the ball game is over
edwin diaz strikes out the side in the
seventh